ce donjon lieu ici un gigolo terre en
salle seront communs conditionnelle il a
fait ressortir la durée personnalité au
revoir chaque jour ce technicien
d'atelier dans l'aéronautique fabrique
des pales d'hélicoptères en composite
mais cet après midi là il reçoit le
titre de meilleur ouvrier de france dans
la catégorie arts et techniques et
matériaux de synthèse
passionné de musique le jeune homme a
réalisé un saxophone uniquement en
carbone difficulté c'est que beaucoup
beaucoup de pièces sur un saxophone
en plus on m'a imposé une réduction
d'échelle non moi je pensais faire
l'échelle 1 mais du coup j'ai été
contraint de faire ça les chèques trois
quarts un vrai défi que florent roche du
à relever pour gagner ses lettres de
noblesse entrée sans diplôme dans un
grand groupe d'aéronautique
ils comptent gravir les échelons grâce à
cette récompense déjà au niveau 2
du statut au sein d'eurocopter donc
de mon travail il ya des évolutions
meilleur statut meilleur salaire
forcément le concours de meilleur
ouvrier de france se déroule sur trois
ans les conditions diffèrent selon les
catégories mais une chose est sûre sa
renommée encourage les générations
d'artisans avesnois c'est la perfection
bon on sait très bien que la perfection
n'existe pas mais ils sont vraiment
firmament de leur profession et surtout
reconnus par leurs pairs
un jeune qui demain aura comme met
apprentissage un meilleur ouvrier de
france
pour lui c'est quelque chose de très
important le concours créé en 1923 à
l'initiative d'albert lebrun récompensé
à l'époque les meilleurs compagnons du
devoir
il est aujourd'hui ouvert à tous les
artisans dans 162 disciplines
différentes et parmi les lauréats une
autre versaillaise veronica bègue tendre
sur porcelaine